The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today, we're moving
on to what will be a major
unit of the course, which is
the topic of efficiency.
Thus far, we focused our
attention on the admittedly
more important problem, getting
our programs to work,
i.e., to do what we
want them to do.
For the next several lectures, I
want to talk about how do we
get them to work quickly
enough to be useful.
It is in practice often a very
important consideration in
designing programs.
The goal is not to make you
an expert in this topic.
It's hard to be an expert
in this topic.
I'm certainly not an expert.
But I want to give you some
intuition about how to
approach the question of
efficiency, how to understand
why some programs take much
longer to run than others, and
how to go about writing programs
that will finish
before you die.
And we'll see that if you
write things wrong, the
programs could, in principle,
run longer than you can.
So why is efficiency
so important?
Earlier in the term, I started
to spend some time talking
about how really fast computers
are and showing you
that we can use brute force
algorithms to solve fairly
large problems.
The difficulty is that some of
the computational problems
we're confronted with are not
fairly large but enormous.
So for example, in my research
group where we work at the
intersection of computer science
and medicine, we have
a big database of roughly a
billion and half heart beats.
And we routinely run
computations that run for two
weeks on that data.
And the only reason they
complete it in two weeks and
not two years is we were
really careful about
efficiency.
So it really can matter.
And increasingly, it matters
is we see the scale of
problems growing.
The thing I want you to take
home to remember is that
efficiency is rarely about
clever coding.
It's not about some little
trick that saves one
instruction here or two
instructions there.
It's really about choosing
the right algorithm.
So the take home message is
that efficiency is about
algorithms, not about
coding details.
Clever algorithms are
hard to invent.
A successful computer scientist
might invent maybe
one in his or her
whole career.
I have to say I invented zero
important algorithms in my
whole career.
Therefore, we don't depend upon
being able to do that.
Instead what we depend upon
is problem reducing.
When confronted with a problem,
we want to reduce it
to a previously solved
problem.
And this is really often the key
to taking some problem and
fitting into a useful
computation.
We sit back, say, well, this
looks a little bit like this
other problem.
How come I transform my problem
to match a problem
that some clever person already
knows how to solve?
Before I spend time on problem
reduction, however, I want to
draw back and look at the
general question of how do we
think about efficiency.
When we think about it, we
think about it in two
dimensions, space and time.
And as we'll see later in the
term, we can often trade one
for the other.
We can make a program run faster
by using more memory or
use less memory at the cost of
making it run more slowly.
For now, and the next
few lectures, I'm
going to focus on time.
Because really, that's mostly
what people worry about these
days when they're dealing
with complexity.
So now, suppose I ask you the
question, how long does some
algorithm implemented by
a program take to run?
How would you go about answering
that question?
Well, you could say, all right,
I'm going to run it on
some computer on some
input and time it.
Look at my watch.
That took three minutes.
I ran this other algorithm,
and it took two minutes.
It's a better algorithm.
Well, that would be really
a bad way to look at it.
The reasons we don't think
about computational
complexity, and that's really
what people call this topic in
terms of how long a program
takes to run on a particular
computer, and it's not
a stable measure.
To do that, it's influenced by
the speed of the machine.
So a program that took 1 minute
on my computer might
take 30 seconds on yours.
It has to do with the cleverness
of the Python
implementation.
Maybe I have a better
implementation of Python than
you do, so my programs will
run a little bit faster.
But most importantly, the reason
we don't depend upon
running programs is it depends
upon the input.
So I might choose one input for
which the program took 2
minutes and another seemingly
similar input in
which it took 1 hour.
So I need to get some way to
talk about it more abstractly.
The way we do that is
by counting the
number of basic steps.
So we define some function,
say time, which maps the
natural numbers to the
natural numbers.
The first n, in this case, the
first natural number, the
argument corresponds to the size
of the input, how big an
input do we want to run
the program on.
And the result of the function
is the number of steps that
the computation will take for
an input of that size.
I'll come back to this in a
little bit more precise detail
momentarily.
A step is an operation that
takes constant time.
And that's important.
So steps are not variable,
but they're constant.
So we have lots of these, for
example, an assignment, a
comparison, an array
access, et cetera.
In looking at computational
complexity in this course,
we're going to use a model
of the computer.
It's known as random access,
a random access machine,
frequently abbreviated as RAM.
In a random access machine,
instructions are executed one
after another, that is to
say they're sequential.
Only one thing happens
at a time.
And we assume constant time
required to access memory.
So we can access at random any
object in memory in the same
amount of time as any
other object.
In the early days of computers,
this model was not
accurate, because memory
was often say, a tape.
And if you wanted to read
something at the end of the
tape, it took a lot longer to
read than something at the
beginning of the tape.
In modern computers, it's
also not quite accurate.
Modern computers have what's
called a memory hierarchy
where you have levels of memory,
the level one cache,
the level two cache,
the actual memory.
And it can differ by say a
factor of a 100, how long it
takes access data
depending upon
whether it's in the cache.
The cache keeps track of
recently accessed objects.
Nevertheless, if we start
going into that level of
detail, we end up losing the
forest for the trees.
So almost everybody when they
actually try and analyze
algorithms typically works
with this model.
We also know in modern computers
that some things
happen in parallel.
But again, for most of
us, these will be
second order effects.
And the random access model is
quite good for understanding
algorithms.
Now when we think about how long
an algorithm will take to
run, there are several
different ways we
could look at it.
We could think of
the best case.
And as we think about these
things, as a concrete example,
we can think about
linear search.
So let's say we have
an algorithm that's
using linear search.
We've looked at that before to
find out whether or not an
element is in the list.
Well, the best case would be
that the first element is
three, and I'm searching for 3,
and I find it right away,
and I stop.
So that would be my best
case complexity.
It's the minimum running time
over all possible inputs.
Is the best case.
I can also look at
the worst case.
What's the worst case
for linear search?
It's not there.
Exactly.
So I go and I have to look at
every element, and whoops,
it's not there.
So the worst case is the maximum
over all possible
inputs of a given size.
The size here is the
length of the list.
And then I can ask what's the
expected or average case, what
would happen most of the time.
The expected case seems, in
principle, like the one we
should care about.
But the truth is when we do
algorithmic analysis, we
almost never deal with
the expected case
because it's too hard.
We think about the expected case
for say linear search, we
can't talk about it without some
detailed model of what
the list itself looks like, what
elements are in it, and
what the distribution of
queries looks like.
Are we most of the time asking
for elements that are not in
the list in which case
the expected
value is out here somewhere?
Or are we most of the time
looking for things that are in
the list in which case the
expected value would be
somewhere near halfway through
the length of the list?
We don't know those things.
We have a tough time modeling
expected value.
And one of the things we know is
that frequently we don't --
when we release a program --
have a good sense of how people
will actually use it.
And so we don't usually
focus on that.
Similarly, we don't usually
focus on the best case.
It would be nice.
But you could imagine that it's
not really what we care
about, what happens when
we get really lucky.
Because we all believe
in Murphy's law.
If something bad can
happen, it will.
And that's why complexity
analysis almost always focuses
on the worst case.
What the worst case does is it
provides an upper bound.
How bad can things
possibly get?
What's the worst that
can happen?
And that's nice because
it means that
there are no surprises.
You say the worst that this
thing can do is look at every
element of the list once.
And so if I know that the list
is a million elements, I know,
OK, it might have to do
a million comparisons.
But it won't have to do any
more than a million.
And so I won't be suddenly
surprised that it takes
overnight to run.
Alas, the worst case
happens often.
We do frequently end up asking
whether something is in a
list, and it's not.
So even though it seems
pessimistic to worry about the
worst case, it is the right
one to worry about.
All right.
Let's look at an example.
So I've got a little
function here, f.
You can see it here.
It's on the handout as well.
First of all, what mathematical
function is f
computing, just to force you
to look at it for a minute?
What's it computing?
Somebody?
It is a function that should
be familiar to
almost all of you.
Nobody?
Pardon.
AUDIENCE: Exponentiation.
PROFESSOR: Exponentiation?
Don't think so.
But I appreciate
you're trying.
It's worth some candy,
not a lot of candy,
but a little candy.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Factorial.
PROFESSOR: Factorial.
Exactly.
It's computing factorial.
Great grab.
So let's think about how long
this will take to run in terms
of the number of steps.
Well, the first thing it does
is it executes an assertion.
And for the sake of argument for
the moment, we can assume
that most instructions in Python
will take one step.
Then, it does an assignment,
so that's two steps.
Then, it goes through
the loop.
Each time through the loop, it
executes three steps, the test
at the start of the
loop and the two
instructions inside the loop.
How many times does it
go through the loop?
Somebody?
Right. n times.
So it will be 2 plus
3 times n.
And then it executes a return
statement at the end.
So if I want to write down the
function that characterizes
the algorithm implemented by
this code, I say it's 2 plus 3
times n plus 1.
Well, I could do that.
But it would be kind of silly.
Let's say n equals 3,000.
Well, if n equals 3,000, this
tells me that it takes 9,000--
well, what does it take?
9,003 steps.
Right.
Well, do I care whether
it's 9,000 or 9,003?
I don't really.
So in fact, when I look at
complexity, I tend to--
I don't tend to I do ignore
additive constants.
So the fact that there's a 2
here and a 1 here doesn't
really matter.
So I say, well, if we're trying
to characterize this
algorithm, let's ignore those.
Because what I really
care about is growth
with respect to size.
How does the running time
grow as the size
of the input grows?
We can even go further.
Do I actually care whether
it's 3,000 or 9,000?
Well, I might.
I might care whether a program
take say 3 hours to run or 9
hours to run.
But in fact, as it gets bigger,
and we really care
about this as things get
bigger, I probably
don't care that much.
If I told you this was going to
take 3,000 years or 9,000
years, you wouldn't care.
Or probably, even if I told you
it was going to take 3,000
days or 9,000 days, you'd say,
well, it's too long anyway.
So typically, we even ignore
multiplicative constants and
use a model of asymptotic growth
that talks about how
the complexity grows as you
reach the limit of the sizes
of the inputs.
This is typically done using
a notation we call big O
notation written as a single
O. So if I write order n,
O(n), what this says is this
algorithm, the complexity, the
time grows linearly with n.
Doesn't say whether it's
3 times n or 2 times n.
It's linear in n is
what this says.
Well, why do we call it big O?
Well, some people think it's
because, oh my God, this
program will never end.
But in fact, no.
This notion was introduced
to computer
science by Donald Knuth.
And he chose the Greek letter
omicron because it was used in
the 19th century by people
developing calculus.
We don't typically write
omicron because
it's harder to types.
So we usually use the capital
Latin letter O, hence, life
gets simple.
What this does is it gives
us an upper bound for the
asymptotic growth
of the function.
So formerly, we would write
something like f of x, where f
is some function of
the input x, is
order, let's say x squared.
That would say it's quadratic
in the size of x.
Formally what this means is
that the function f--
I should probably write
this down--
the function f grows no faster
than the quadratic
polynomial x squared.
So let's look at what
this means.
I wrote a little program that
talks about some of the--
I should say probably most
popular values we see.
So some of the most popular
orders we would write down, we
often see order 1.
And what that means
is constant.
The time required is
independent of
the size of the input.
It doesn't say it's one step.
But it's independent
of the input.
It's constant.
We often see order log n,
logarithmic growth.
Order n, linear.
One we'll see later this
week is nlog(n).
This is called log linear.
And we'll see why that occurs
surprisingly often.
Order n to the c where c is
some constant, this is
polynomial.
A common polynomial would be
squared as in quadratic.
And then, if we're terribly
unlucky, you run into things
that are order c to the
n exponential in
the size of the input.
To give you an idea of what
these classes actually mean, I
wrote a little program that
produces some plots.
Don't worry about what
the code looks like.
In a few weeks, you'll
be able to write
such programs yourself.
Not only will you be able
to, you'll be forced to.
So I'm just going to run this
and produce some plots showing
different orders of growth.
All right.
This is producing
these blocks.
Excuse me.
I see.
So let's look at the plots.
So here, I've plotted
linear growth
versus logarithmic growth.
And as you can see, it's
quite a difference.
If we can manage to get a
logarithmic algorithm, it
grows much more slowly than
a linear algorithm.
And we saw this when we looked
at the graded advantage of
binary search as opposed
to linear search.
Actually, this is linear
versus log linear.
What happened to figure one?
Well, we'll come back to it.
So you'll see here that
log linear is
much worse than linear.
So this factor of nlog(n)
actually makes a considerable
difference in running time.
Now, I'm going to compare a
log linear to quadratic, a
small degree polynomial.
As you can see, it almost looks
like log linear is not
growing at all.
So as bad as log linear looked
when we compared it to linear,
we see that compared to
quadratic, it's pretty great.
And what this tells us is that
in practice, even a quadratic
algorithm is often impractically
slow, and we
really can't use them.
And so in practice, we worked
very hard to avoid even
quadratic, which somehow
doesn't seem like it
should be so bad.
But in fact, as you can see,
it gets bad quickly.
Yeah, this was the log versus
linear, not surprising.
And now, if we look at quadratic
versus exponential,
we can see hardly anything.
And that's because exponential
is growing so quickly.
So instead, what we're going to
do is I'm going to plot the
y-axis logarithmically just so
we can actually see something.
And as you can see on input of
size 1,000, an exponential
algorithm is roughly order
10 to the 286th.
That's an unimaginably
large number.
Right?
I don't know what it compares
to, the number of atoms in the
universe, or something
ridiculous, or maybe more.
But we can't possibly think of
running an algorithm that's
going to take this long.
It's just not even
conceivable.
So exponential, we sort of throw
up our hands and say
we're dead.
We can't do it.
And so nobody uses exponential
algorithms for everything, yet
for anything.
Yet as we'll see, there are
problems that we care about
that, in principle, can only
be solved by exponential
algorithms.
So what do we do?
As we'll see, well, we
usually don't try
and solve those problems.
We try and solve some
approximation to those problems.
Or we use some other tricks to
say, well, we know the worst
case will be terrible, but
here's how we're going to
avoid the worst case.
We'll see a lot of that towards
the end of the term.
The moral is try not to do
anything that's worse than log
linear if you possibly can.
Now some truth in advertising,
some caveats.
If I look at my definition of
what big O means, I said it
grows no faster than.
So in principle, I could say,
well, what the heck, I'll just
write 2 to the x here.
And it's still true.
It's not faster than that.
It's not what we actually
want to do.
What we actually want
is a type bound.
We'd like to say it's no faster
than this, but it's no
slower than this either, to try
and characterize the worst
cases precisely as we can.
Formally speaking, a theorist
used something called big
Theta notation for this.
They write a theta instead of
an O. However, most of the
time in practice, when somebody
writes something like
f of x is order x squared, what
they mean is the worst
case is really about
x squared.
And that's the way we're
going to use it here.
We're not going to try
and get too formal.
We're going to do what people
actually do in practice when
they talk about complexity.
All right, let's look at
another example now.
Here, I've written factorial
recursively.
Didn't even try to disguise
what it was.
So let's think about how
we would analyze the
complexity of this.
Well, we know that we can ignore
the first two lines of
code because those are just
the additives pieces.
We don't care about that--
the first line, and the
if, and the return.
So what's the piece
we care about?
We care about the number of
times the factorial is called.
In the first implementation of
factorial, we cared about the
number of iterations
of a loop.
Now instead of using a loop, you
use recursion to do more
or less the same thing.
And so we care about
the number of
times fact is called.
How many times will
that happen?
Well, let's think about why I
know this doesn't run forever,
because that's always the way
we really think about
complexity in some sense.
I know it doesn't run forever
because each time I call
factorial, I call it on a number
one smaller than the
number before.
So how many times can
I do that if I start
with a number n?
n times, right?
So once again, it's order n.
So the interesting thing we see
here is that essentially,
I've given you the same
algorithm recursively and
iteratively.
Not surprisingly, even though
I've coded it differently,
it's the same complexity.
Now in practice, the recursive
one might take a little longer
to run, because there's a
certain overhead to function
calls that we don't have
with while loops.
But we don't actually
care about that.
Its overhead is one of those
multiplicative constants I
said we're going to ignore.
And in fact, it's a very small
multiplicative constant.
It really doesn't make
much of a difference.
So how do I decide whether to
use recursion or iteration has
nothing to do with efficiency,
it's whichever is more
convenient to code.
In this case, I kind of like
the fact that recursive
factorial is a little neater.
So that's what I would use
and not worry about the
efficiency.
All right.
Let's look at another example.
How about g?
What's the complexity of g?
Well, I can ignore the
first statement.
But now I've got two
nested loops.
How do I go and think
about this?
The way I do it is I start by
finding the inner loop.
How many times do I go through
the inner loop?
I go through the inner
loop n times, right?
So it executes the inner
for statement is
going to be order n.
The next question I ask is how
many times do I start the
inner loop up again?
That's also order n times.
So what's the complexity
of this?
Somebody?
AUDIENCE: n-squared.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I think I heard the
right answer.
It's order n-squared.
Because I execute the inner
loop n times, or each time
around is n, then I multiply it
by n because I'm doing the
outer loop n times.
So the inner loop is
order n-squared.
That makes sense?
So typically, whenever I have
nested loops, I have to do
this kind of reasoning.
Same thing if I have recursion
inside a loop or nested
recursions.
I start at the inside and
work my way out is the
way I do the analysis.
Let's look at another example.
It's kind of a different take.
How about h?
What's the complexity of h?
First of all, what's h doing?
Kind of always a good
way to start.
What is answer going to be?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The sum of the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Exactly.
It's going to be the
sum of the digits.
Spring training is already
under way,
so sum of the digits.
And what's the complexity?
Well, we can analyze it.
Right away, we know
we can ignore
everything except the loop.
So how many times do I
go through this loop?
It depends upon the number
of digits in the string
representation of
the int, right?
Now, if I were careless, I would
write something like
order n, where n is the
number of digits in s.
But really, I'm not allowed
to do that.
Why not?
Because I have to express the
complexity in terms of the
inputs to the program.
And s is not an input.
s is a local variable.
So somehow, I'm going to have to
express the complexity, not
in terms of s, but
in terms of what?
x.
So that's no go.
So what is in terms of x?
How many digits?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it constant?
PROFESSOR: It's not constant.
No.
Because I'll have more
digits in a billion
than I will in four.
Right.
Log --
in this case, base 10 of x.
The number of decimal digits
required to express an integer
is the log of the magnitude
of that integer.
You think about we looked at
binary numbers and decimal
numbers last lecture, that was
exactly what we were doing.
So that's the way I have
to express this.
Now, what's the moral here?
The thing I really care about
is not that this is how you
talk about the number
of digits in an int.
What I care about is
that you always
have to be very careful.
People often think that they're
done when they write
something like order n.
But they're not until they tell
you what n means, Because
that can be pretty subtle.
Order x would have been wrong
because it's not the magnitude
of the integer x.
It's this is what controls
the growth.
So whenever you're looking at
complexity, you have to be
very careful what you mean,
what the variables are.
This is particularly true now
when you look at functions say
with multiple inputs.
Ok.
Let's look at some
more examples.
So we've looked before
at search.
So this is code you've
seen before, really.
Here's a linear search
and a binary search.
And in fact, informally, we've
looked at the complexity of
these things before.
And we can run them, and we can
see how they will grow.
But it won't surprise you.
So if we look at the
linear search--
whoops, I'm printing
the values here,
just shows it works.
But now, the binary search, what
we're going to look at is
how it grows.
This is exactly the search
we looked at before.
And the thing I want you to
notice, and as we looked at
before, we saw it was
logarithmic is that as the
size of the list grows, doubles,
I only need one more
step to do the search.
This is the beauty of a
logarithmic algorithm.
So as I go from a 100, which
takes 7 steps, to 200,
it only takes 8.
1,600 takes 11.
And when I'm all the way up to
some very big number, and I'm
not even sure what that number
is, it took 23 steps.
But very slow growth.
So that's a good thing.
What's the order of this?
It's order n where n is what?
Order log n where n is what?
Let's just try and write
it carefully.
Well, it's order length
of the list.
We don't care what the actual
members of the list are.
Now, that's an interesting
question to ask.
Let's look at the code
for a minute.
Is that a valid assumption?
Well, it seems to be when
we look at my test.
But let's look at what
I'm doing here.
So a couple of things
I want to point out.
One is I used a very common
trick when dealing with these
kinds of algorithms.
You'll notice that I have
something called bsearch and
something called search.
All search does is
called bsearch.
Why did I even bother
with search?
Why didn't I just with my code
down here call bsearch with
some initial values?
The answer is really, I started
with this search.
And a user of search shouldn't
have to worry that I got
clever and went from this linear
search to a binary
search or maybe some more
complex search yet.
I need to have a consistent
interface
for the search function.
And the interface is what it
looks like to the caller.
And it says when I call
it, it just takes
a list and an element.
It shouldn't have to take the
high bound and the lower bound
as arguments.
Because that really is
not intrinsic to
the meaning of search.
So I typically will organize
my program by having this
search look exactly like this
search to a caller.
And then, it does whatever
it needs to do
to call binary search.
So that's usually the way
you do these things.
It's very common with recursive
algorithms, various
things where you need some
initial value that's only
there for the initial call,
things like that.
Let me finish--
wanted to point out is the use
of this global variable.
So you'll notice down
here, I define
something called NumCalls.
Remember we talked
about scopes.
So this is now an identifier
that exists in the outermost
scope of the program.
Then in bsearch, I used it.
But I said I'm going to use
this global variable, this
variable declared outside
the scope of
bsearch inside bsearch.
So it's this statement that
tells me not to create a new
local variable here but to use
the one in the outer scope.
This is normally considered
poor programming practice.
Global variables can
often lead to
very confusing programs.
Occasionally, they're useful.
Here it's pretty useful because
I'm just trying to
keep track of a number of times
this thing is called.
And so I don't want a new
variable generated each time
it's instantiated.
Now, you had a question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just checking.
The order len L, the size
of the list is the
order of which search?
PROFESSOR: That's the order
of the linear search.
The order of the binary search
is order log base 2 of L--
sorry, not of L, right?
Doesn't make sense to take
the log of a list of the
length of the list.
Typically, we don't bother
writing base 2.
If it's logarithmic, it doesn't
really very much
matter what the base is.
You'll still get that
very slow growth.
Log base 10, log base 2, not
that much difference.
So we typically just
write log.
All right.
People with me?
Now, for this to be true, or in
fact, even if we go look at
the linear search, there's
kind of an assumption.
I'm assuming that I can extract
the elements from a
list and compare them to a
value in constant time.
Because remember, my model of
computation says that every
step takes the same amount
of time, roughly.
And if I now look say a binary
search, you'll see I'm doing
something that apparently
looks a little bit
complicated up here.
I am looking at L of low and
comparing it to e, and L of
high and comparing it to e.
How do I know that's
constant time?
Maybe it takes me order length
of list time to extract the
last element.
So I've got to be very careful
when I look at complexity, not
to think I only have to look
at the complexity of the
program itself, that is to say,
in this case, the number
of recursive calls, but is
there something that it's
doing inside this function that
might be more complex
than I think.
As it happens, in this case,
this rather complicated
expression can be done
in constant time.
And that will be the
first topic of
the lecture on Thursday.